believe in what you're doing for those
of you who watch my videos you know I
stand for believe I got the shirt it's
at the end of all my videos and most
people think believe is just
self-confidence believe in yourself
but it's more than that it's also
believing in what you're doing
believing that you're doing the right
thing and believing that if you are
doing the right thing that it's gonna
work out eventually it's going to work
out and sometimes you need to have that
internal belief because it's gonna get
so hard and the only thing that keeps
you going is that belief that you're
doing the right thing and that it will
work out one of my favorite stories is
of Arthur Blank and Bernie Marcus then
the cofounders of The Home Depot
started in 1978 and they believed that
people wanted to do home renovations
themselves that every time there was
something wrong with their house they
didn't have to call a plumber or a
handyman to come and fix it and they
wanted to demystify that whole industry
to say hey look we believe in you you
guys can do this yourself and they set
up shop and I said we want to provide
the widest selection of products are the
best possible prices have knowledgeable
staff to provide the best possible
customer experience and also put on
workshops to help educate people how
they can do things themselves around the
house and so they set up shop and they
raise money and they started their first
store in Atlanta and they got so excited
right they had all suppliers lined up
they had their store that they spent all
this time creating this vision that they
had all lined up with their head how
everything was gonna work out it was the
right thing to do the time line was now
let's go do this thing and they had
their kids they gave them $1 bills to
hand out at their grand opening so that
everybody who comes in sending in line
give them $1.00 bill as a thank-you for
coming to our grand opening and they
figured you know bite by 11 by 12 we're
gonna be out of we're gonna be out of
dollar bills because gonna be so packed
and come 5 or 6 o'clock at night the
kids were chasing people down in the
parking lot trying to give the money
away because it was such a total failure
of that grand opening so what do you do
you know you have this big vision you
have this great thing that you think is
the right thing to do and it totally
flops and you may owe money to investors
or you may you know put tons of time and
effort and energy into this thing and
it's not working out they got so bad and
so depressing that one of the founders
his wife wouldn't let him shave for a
few days because she didn't want him
anywhere near a razor blade
that's how sad and depressed he was she
thought that he might try to kill
himself and so how do you keep going you
know you've got to be a little bit crazy
to be an entrepreneur you've got to
believe in what you're doing so much
that even though you're putting all this
stress on your family you've invested
all your money
you've taken on money from other people
you're yourself worth you feel like a
total failure how do you keep going and
it's from believing that you're doing
the right thing like this is going to
work out this is badly needed and it
will work out even though there's no
evidence right you spend all this money
you open this store you can't even give
money away to people to come into your
location but they kept on going because
they believed in the concept so much and
they kept providing great service and
they kept providing workshops and they
look just for little signs that things
are working and in the early days one of
those little signs was a woman who had a
great shopping experience she came back
and she gave them a gift
she gave the founders a gift just to say
thank you for the wonderful experience I
had here an overtime momentum built and
customer customers came in through
word-of-mouth
they had a great shopping experience The
Home Depot and they told their friends
and they told their friends and they
told their friends people started to
come a momentum built and you need to
allow for time for momentum to build
things just don't happen overnight
and Home Depot eventually grew to become
a multi-billion dollar company but it
could have all been nothing right it
could have been all for nothing they
could have quit after that grand opening
when they owed money to people when they
were down in their lives were they're so
depressed that they thought about
killing themselves but they believed in
what they were doing they believed it
was the right thing and they believed
against all odds that it was gonna work
out somehow someway it was gonna work
out you need to believe in what you're
doing if you're doing this business just
trying to make money then fine quit stop
it's not gonna work
but if you are passionately behind what
you're trying to do you know you're
helping people
then you have to believe that by doing
the right thing eventually it's going to
work out and you have to find a way to
keep going it's too important to you
it's too important to your family it's
too important to all the people whose
lives are gonna change so believe you
guys like this video thumbs up below
let me know what you think let me know
your business is all about let me know
what you believe in leave a comment
underneath and click on my face
subscribe to the channel
thank you so much I'll see you soon